Here's a very interesting question.
What is Pi?
Assume we draw a circle of radius three centimeters.
It will look something like this.
As we know this red boundary of the circle will be its perimeter.
We have a special name for the perimeter of a circle.
It's called the circumference of the circle.
But how do we measure the circumference of the circle?
The circumference is round
and the scale we used to measure any length is straight.
It's simple.
We just place the redline like this.
Like a straight line and measured this length using a scale.
This circumference of this particular circle,
will measure approximately eighteen point eight five centimeters.
It means if we draw a circle of radius three centimeters
and measure its perimeter it will equal
eighteen point eight five centimeters.
Let's also note the diameter of the circle.
The diameter of a circle is two times its radius.
So the diameter will be 2 multiplied by three
which equals six centimeters.
For this circle,
these are the values we have for circumference and the diameter.
Now, let's draw a circle of radius four centimeters.
This time as well, we measure its circumference.
This red mark will be the circumference and to measure it,
we make the curved line straight.
This will be the length of the boundary.
For this circle we get the circumference
as approximately twenty-five point one centimeters.
The diameter will be twice its radius which equals eight centimeters.
So we have the circumference and the diameter values
for each of the circles.
Now here's the best part.
If we calculate the value of circumference
by the diameter in the first case,
we will come up with approximately 3.14.
What do you think will be the value of circumference
by diameter in the second case?
Guess what! It will be the same.
Approximately 3.14 again,
No matter which circle you look at
this value of the circumference by the diameter
will always be approximately equal to this value.
This value is called Pi.
Remember, both these values are approximations.
As circumference by diameter equals Pi.
We can say that the circumference of a circle
equals Pi multiplied by the diameter.
If we call the diameter D,
then the formula can be written as, pi multiplied by D.
Which can also be written as pi multiplied by 2R,
because the diameter is twice the radius.
So the circumference of a circle is written as 2 Pi R.
This is a very important formula
as it gives you the value of the circumference
even if you just have the radius of the circle.
There is another important thing about this special constant Pi.
We get the same value if we divide 22 by 7.
So the value of pi approximately equals
3.14
or 22 by 7.